So Donald Trump is using Corona virus to push
a very nationalist agenda and to fire up the
most rabid ultra nationalists in his base.
The latest example we already talked about
at the top of the show, which is Donald Trump
announcing on Twitter that all immigration
to the United States is suspended.
Trump tweeted last night, again, just a quick
reminder, quote, In light of the attack from
the invisible enemy, as well as the great
need to protect the jobs of our great American
citizens, I will be signing an executive order.
To temporarily suspend immigration into the
United States, we don't know what temporary
means.
We don't know the legal basis.
We don't even know if this is legal.
But what we've known for a long time is that
Donald Trump would be as ultra nationalist,
the president, as he could get away with.
Not necessarily because these are the policies
that he believes in or that he actually thinks
are the best policies for the country.
Maybe he does.
Maybe he doesn't, doesn't really matter.
But because from the start of his campaign,
Donald Trump has positioned himself as the
nationalist candidate and it has worked to
bamboozle voters into supporting him.
If you go back to the campaign in 2015 and
into 2016, it was China's killing us.
I know about how to stop us from getting screwed
on trade deals, even though he didn't.
But it was very, very effective.
We don't win anymore.
No more Mexican rapists are going to be coming
here.
We're suspending Muslim immigration to the
United States.
It's all nationalist language.
And from day one at his inauguration, that
language of America first referencing an ugly
nationalist slogan from the mid 20th century.
There have been endless examples during the
presidency.
But today I want to focus in on what's been
done during Corona virus to push the nationalist
rhetoric.
And before I do that, just remember hyper
nationalism, ultra nationalism.
This is a common element for lack of a better
term of fascism.
And as we followed throughout the Trump presidency,
we have a number of different elements of
fascism that are noticeable.
Trump is not a dictator.
Fascism is a form of far right authoritarian
ultra nationalism, often headed up by a dictator.
It often includes police states and lots of
things that we don't have in American society
right now.
But that hyper nationalism is part of it.
And Donald Trump is very much excelling there.
So let's look at our list.
Under the guise of Corona virus, we've seen
the entire premise of the response from Trump
be focused around China is bad and we are
good.
So we had early on Trump first saying China's
got this under control.
Once it became clear that they didn't have
it under control, Trump very much reversed
and was calling it the Wu Hand virus.
He was calling it the Chinese virus and the
rest of it.
You all know about it.
This was setting up the early stages of a
nationalistic response to Corona virus.
Then, of course, there's always some truth
to these things.
The virus did originate in China.
Then it's we're closing borders.
We're shutting down.
We are isolated now.
That was the right move.
Every country mostly did it.
But what we're talking about is the building
rhetoric of ultra nationalism during the corona
virus response.
Then Trump started with we've got to start
producing everything domestically.
We can't rely on China for masks.
We can't rely on Italy for ventilators or
whatever the case was that each product was
coming from.
We've got to bring all our production domestically.
And of course, that's partially true now,
which is that if we produced all of this stuff
all along, we'd probably have somewhat of
an easier time getting more of these items
right now.
But it's distracting from the real failure
because the real failure is not we should
have gotten the stuff from American companies
instead of foreign companies all along.
You can debate that.
Maybe it's true.
Maybe it's not.
The real failure was disbanding the pandemic
response team, not strategically increasing
stockpiles of these elements, not distributing
these earlier rather than playing catch up
in late March.
That was the real mistake and it would have
avoided the panic.
So, sure, you can get them all along from
the United States or from other countries.
The issue is not so much where these items
are produced.
It's that we weren't stockpiling them and
we were unprepared and late in distributing
them.
Then it became we must open the country for
liberty and freedom.
It's a constitutional issue.
This is America.
We're meant to be open.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Fomenting the mass gatherings to protest governors
putting in place public health guidelines,
insisting that these crowds are behaving appropriately.
Of course, the crowds made up almost exclusively
of Trump ists Don't Tread on me tea party
types.
Alex Jones style conspiracy theories.
All very nationalist groups.
Trump very much instigating and and firing
them up.
And then now we get to stop all immigration.
There is this phrase, never let a good crisis
go to waste.
The phrase has been attributed to Winston
Churchill, I believe falsely.
I don't think it's a Churchill phrase.
I've seen it attributed to Saul Alinsky.
I'm not actually sure where it originated,
but it very much applies here.
It's not been put in place more acutely than
during the Trump administration and specifically
during the Corona virus fiasco.
And it may actually propel Trump to reelect.
If we're not careful, the nationalist rhetoric,
which very often confused people in the sense
that they believe Trump was good on trade
when Trump didn't really know anything about
trade.
But it got people to say this is the guy that
will bring America back, so to speak.
It worked during his campaign.
And we have to understand that it may well
work for Donald Trump's own reelection.
Ultra nationalism under the guise of corona
virus laughable at its face.
Things are going so well that we should reopen.
But at the same time, things are going so
poorly.
We need to take the unprecedented step of
suspending all immigration to the United States.
Completely incoherent.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a packed program for you today.
Really glad you're with us.